ايضا قال قائد اللواء الثالث في الجيش
الاوكراني
انها قوات بلاده نفذت ما وصفها بعمليه
تطهير في الضفه الغربيه لقناه
الواقعه جنوب ضخمه
[موسيقى]
هزم مقاتلون الكتيبه الثالثه التابعه
للواء الحرس السابع والخمسين في الجيش
الروسي تم القضاء على ثلاثين مقاتل روسيا
وجرح خمسون واسره العشرات كما تم تدمير
الياتهم العسكريه المواقع التي كانت تشكل
جسرا للعدو على الضفه الغربيه لقناه
تم تطهيرها بالكامل ولا توجد اي قوات
معاديه في ذلك الاتجاه
على الجانب الروسي قال المتحدث باسم قوات
الجنوب الروسيه باديما ستافيييف ان القوات
الروسيه صدت هجمات اوكرانيه نفذتها 10
وحدات من المركبات المدرعه في اتجاه بخموت
واضاف ان قوته تصدت لاربع هجمات في محيط
ودمرت وحده مشاه عند محور مارينكا جنوبيه
صدت قوتنا كل الهجمات الاوكرانيه عند محور
بخموت التي شاركت فيها 10 وحدات من
المركبات المدرعه كما صدت قواتنا هجمات
اوكرانيه في محيط
استهدفت قواتنا وحدات اللواء 129 للدفاع
الاقليميه الاوكرانيه في نوفا لينوفو في
دونيسك ووحده بوشاه معاديه في منطقه
مارينكا حيث تم القضاء على جزء كبير منها